the more sex you had the more children
you had yeah but now
that's why you only had back in the day
you only had sex with one person because
you're gonna have kids with them but now
there's less kids there's more sex
because there's contraception and that's
what the men don't want so you might say
you know what they might want me because
i've not had no children but you might
have
no children but 15 previous partners
and that's the difference
but how would they know that's another
thing like i feel like men talk we
can see anyway i mean the same way when
you're dating you're vetting a woman
you're vetting a man i'm vetting a woman
once you're with them for a while you'll
start seeing
even if you never say to me i was at 15
guys
you'll start seeing little things that
will present this like they say let a
woman talk she'll tell on herself yes
definitely but um and and if you if this
is the guy you want don't you want to be
honest like don't you want him to really
know you inside out
i would agree but if you feel that
there's nothing wrong with it
it doesn't matter then you should be
sticking to what you think i've been
with 20 guys
now do you want me
and
if you if you can't say it with your
chairs maybe you shouldn't have been
with 20 guys i would agree but then
you know what yeah
i would agree but the way you guys are
placing value on body count it would
like i in my head that would make women
want to lie about it that's what i mean
like that's the women that wouldn't want
to be honest because of the value that's
placed on it well they they do lie about
it that's why you're supposed to start
for me young
yeah then you don't have to lie i've had
free yeah and you say it with your chest
no but this is what i'm saying you're
saying that
so i'm going back to her point because
she said that
a man wouldn't want a woman with the
history with a long with a long history
but i'm saying
because you're placing because our
generation places so much value on it
that's what's going to give women the
tendency to lie and your point was women
wouldn't lie because they would want to
be honest with whoever it is but because
you're placing value it's like a circle
it's like we're going around in circles
no no he's not saying that women
wouldn't lie he's saying like
now you have to live with a secret the
rest of your life like your start in
your marriage yeah
yeah and so wouldn't you like yourself
want to be with someone there you
thought you was being honest with well
because i don't necessarily think it's
like
over for girls that have a high body
count because i ask guys this question
all the time i say okay would you prefer
a girl with this many body like a higher
body count but she hasn't slept with
anyone you know
or i say would you rather a girl that
slept with two guys you know there's the
only other guy she slept with
every guy every guy says hi body count
as long as i don't know him as long as i
don't know him
so so so girls can get away with it they
just move right
but like the issue is it's internal
because it hurts your ability to pair
bond and so you can't connect with the
guy you're supposed to be with as much
if you've been with like guy after guy
after guy after guy you're exchanging
energies yeah i do get what you mean but
again i feel like another assumption
i thought is probably the case but
another assumption we're making is that
the older you are the higher your body
count is
well it's more likely yeah it is you're
gonna have had it's just okay if you're
18 or if you're 21 right
versus 35.
you're gonna have had more relationships
by the time you're 35. and i know like i
know the girls
trust me i i see some of my
i'm not going to name names but some of
the young these young girls these days
i'm like y'all are wild and they're
they're like they're younger than me
right but they've definitely been with
way more people than i have but
it's just
i put it like
they can't undo the damage to themselves
yeah and there's still some value in
youth so they still have like that that
youth aspect and that's valuable to a
guy
so would you say that someone that's
35 with a lower body count would be seen
as more valuable than someone that's
younger the higher body can't i don't
know ask the guys um
that's an i'd say it's an equal one only
because
someone that's young with a high body
count has youth
someone that's old with a low body count
doesn't have youth but they have body
counts so yeah it's a it's a catch 22.
but typically like women at 35 have like
the worst of both worlds like i would
say it's an exception that a girl makes
it to 35 and hasn't slept with more than
five people but you could find a girl at
21 that that hasn't done that a lot
easier
yeah
just in like law in general right
there's exceptions like there's a guy in
my show that married a girl in her 30s
that was a virgin like there's
exceptions it's just not the rule
yeah definitely is i feel like again it
just goes
it depends highly on what the person
values
in a woman
yeah hey look i'm i this is advice for
you because more so like you're a pretty
girl and more so you'd find someone
a lot easier better that you'd deem high
value
if you was to
vet now as opposed to
at 35
and like a lot i don't aim on being i
don't know who will be a single at 35 i
just don't
agree
with because the problem with that term
left over is i feel like it's all based
on fertility like you're placing a
woman's value on her ability to have
kids
that's my problem oh it's because what
does the guy get out of the deal
like why would a guy get married most of
the time it's four kids
yeah i do i do get women but it's just
me personally i'm not saying there's a
problem with men doing that but me
personally i just don't think
a woman's value should be based on her
ability to have children well we can say
it shouldn't but we but it is what it is
right like i don't i don't enjoy that
you know the older i get the less value
i'm going to have
but it is what it is like i think it's
worse to ignore reality
and just hope for the best when i turn
35.
i would say it's definitely true
again like i said like me personally i
wouldn't wait till 35 to be considering
but my problem is i just don't like i
disagree with the time left over like i
i just said i'd really disagree with
that do you think it's untrue
i wouldn't say it's untrue but i
disagree with it like something so
something could be real like it's real
but i still something could be real like
this is the real life case but i still
disagree okay so so in a way you don't
disagree you agree you just don't like
it
um
or is it a wording
yeah you can't change that let's say but
just know that's what's left over it's
the chinese thing that left her isn't it
[Music]
should we make merch with leftover women
yeah
like left over it sounds like food like
it just sounds so derogative sometimes
the leftovers are nice but the thing is
what food that everybody else is picked
at yeah right i mean oh would you want
food that everybody else has picked out
you're hungry you see a plate of food
there and everybody's picked it would
you really go and eat it
you're hungry that's the leftovers
that's left there would you gonna eat
him speaking to the mac
you wouldn't go and eat it because it's
leftovers everybody's been at it
and that leftover food on that plate is
the woman
everybody's picked at it there's nothing
there that all the chicken wings they
left all the bones left they left all
the gristle everything's there who wants
it
not me
it's gotta be somebody's starving
right and that's what the women are
gonna end up with we're not gonna say
you're gonna be single you're gonna end
up with somebody starving or hard up who
can do no better but eat the leftovers
there's men out there for women like
that
do you ever